Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Dear Mrs Thatcher, You have succeeded where we failed. Since the dispatch of the task force to the Falkland Islands, 266 Argentine military advisers have been withdrawn from Central America. Thank you. Yours in the democratic struggle,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家番外节目、无广告收听、剧集抢先体验以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区的会员资格，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。亲爱的撒切尔夫人：你们取得了我们未能实现的成功。自特遣舰队被派遣至福克兰群岛以来，已有266名阿根廷军事顾问撤出中美洲。谢谢你们。在民主斗争中与你们同在，
FDR, the Revolutionary democratic front of El Salvador. Improbable fans of The Iron Lady. And what makes that even more extraordinary is that the message came with a bunch of flowers. So, Dominic, I got that, of course, from your brilliant book, Who Dares Wins, with its climactic account of the Falklands War. The first three episodes, we've looked at the causes of the war, early stages. And in the final episode, we looked at the British land victory, the surrender of Port Stanley. What is the impact of this back in Britain? Presumably forrs thatcher it's i mean it's you know all her christmases come at once it is it's absolutely um it's absolutely colossal whether it's
FDR，萨尔瓦多革命民主阵线。“铁娘子”的意料之外的粉丝。更不可思议的是，这封信还附带了一束鲜花。所以，多米尼克，这段话我当然是从你的杰作《敢作敢为》（Who Dares Wins）中摘录的，书中对马岛战争有高潮迭起的描述。在前三集里，我们探讨了战争的起因和早期阶段。而在最后一集里，我们关注了英军的地面胜利以及斯坦利港的投降。这在英国国内造成了什么样的影响？对撒切尔夫人来说，这可以说是——我的意思是，你知道的，所有的圣诞节愿望同时实现了，绝对是……这绝对是极其巨大的，至于它是否具有
transformative is a different question but it definitely has well so dominic on that i'm just going to say for the listeners that we have we have quite a lot of questions about the overall legacy yeah so i'll ask those in the second half but if we get just for now let's just focus on the immediate impact so she announces the uh surrender nine o'clock in the evening um on whenever it is the um the 14th of june uh she goes in she says uh you know white flags are flying over port stanley and And there's a huge roar from the both sides of the House of Commons. Because in those days, of course, the Commons often, you know, the meetings went on long. And they had ridiculous kind of timetables.
变革性，则是另一个问题，但它确实——那么，多米尼克，关于这一点，我先对听众们说一下，我们收到了相当多关于整体历史遗产的问题，是的，所以我会把这些留到下半场再问，不过现在，让我们先专注于直接的影响。因此，她宣布了……呃，投降的消息是在晚上九点钟，在那个什么日子来着，呃，6月14日，她走进议会，说，呃，你知道的，白旗正在斯坦利港上空飘扬，下议院两党爆发了巨大的欢呼声。因为在那个年代，当然了，下议院的会议经常，你知道的，开得很久。而且他们的时间表安排得非常荒谬。
And also not televised, is it? Not televised. So it's only on the radio, but it's also late at night. Michael Foote, the Labour leader who we talked about earlier on, he gives a very gracious tribute to her. He says, if the news is confirmed, there'll be great congratulations from the House tomorrow to the British forces who've conducted themselves in this manner, and, if I may say so, to the right honourable lady. He congratulates her.
而且当时也没有电视转播，对吧？没有电视转播。所以只能通过广播收听，而且时间也很晚。工党领袖迈克尔·富特（Michael Foot），也就是我们之前谈到过的那位，对她给予了非常优雅的赞扬。他说，如果这个消息得到证实，明天议会将向以这种方式表现自己的英国武装部队，如果我能这么说的话，也将向右翼议员女士致以热烈的祝贺。他向她表示祝贺。
And that is actually, you know, given her later very controversial reputation, that's a really interesting and illuminating moment. And actually, she... He was an honourable man. He wasn't. Well, he was an honourable man. He and, I mean, we haven't talked about Jim Callaghan in this series at all, Tom, which is a shocking oversight.
考虑到她后来极具争议的声誉，这其实是一个非常有趣且具有启示意义的时刻。而且实际上，他……他是个正派的人。他不是。好吧，他是个正派的人。而且，我的意思是，我们在本系列中根本没有谈到吉姆·卡拉汉（Jim Callaghan），汤姆，这是一个令人震惊的疏忽。
Jim Callaghan had also been, her predecessor as prime minister, had also been very, very pro the war and also pays a tribute to her. And generally, I think in the couple of days after the surrender, people sort of queuing up to pay tribute to her. Would it be fair to say Mrs. Thatcher is a famously divisive figure? And she almost seemed to thrive on the fact that people disliked her as well as supported her. Would it be fair to say that in the immediate aftermath of the Falklands victory, she kind of briefly becomes a unifying figure? Would that be going too far? I think it may be going a tiny bit too far. But I do think this is the unique moment in her political career where she is i mean probably the only exceptions when the ira tried to kill her in 1984 uh is when she she
吉姆·卡拉汉也曾担任过首相，作为她的前任，他也非常非常支持这场战争，并且也对她表达了赞敬。总的来说，我认为在投降后的几天里，人们都在排队向她致敬。说撒切尔夫人是一个广受争议的人物，这公平吗？而且她似乎非常享受人们既讨厌她又支持她的状态。如果说在马岛胜利后的紧要关头，她短暂地变成了一个具有凝聚力的人物，这样说公平吗？会不会有些过头了？我认为可能稍微有点过头了。但我确实认为这是她政治生涯中独一无二的时刻，当时她是——可能唯一的例外是1984年爱尔兰共和军试图刺杀她的时候——那是她
gets a lot of praise from all sides so i've got a quote here from the daily mirror so the daily mirror had really absolutely the voice of the labour party um had had had led the attack on her economic policies front page after front, for the first part of her first term. And it said, you know, now, had things gone wrong, we would have been, had things gone wrong, it says, it would have been known as Thatcher's War. But now things have gone right, nobody should deny her the credit. The scale of her triumph in both military and political terms is amazing. I mean, that's an extraordinary thing for a Labour, such a staunch Labour pay to say about somebody whose economic policies
获得了来自各方的赞誉。所以我这里有一段《每日镜报》的引文：《每日镜报》绝对是工党的声音，在她的第一任期的前段，曾对她的经济政策发起了一次又一次头版头条的猛烈攻击。上面写着，你知道的，如果事情搞砸了，我们本会——如果事情搞砸了，上面写着，这本会被称为“撒切尔的战争”。但现在事情进展顺利，谁也不应该否认她应得的功劳。她在军事和政治层面取得的胜利规模是惊人的。我的意思是，对于一个工党、一个如此坚定的工党喉舌来说，对一个经济政策如此尖锐、如此具有争议的人说出这样的话，是一件非常了不起的事情。
have been so abrasive and so controversial. So it is a rare moment when, for once, as you say, and certainly across the political spectrum, with the exception of people on pretty much the far left, so Tony Benn, Ken Livingstone,ston jeremy corbin people of that kind arthur scargill um she's getting a lot of a lot of praise and how long does it take for that to wear off for that to wear off yeah a couple of days um no i think she's she has a bit of a honeymoon that probably lasts for another year or so, actually, probably until her re-election victory in the summer of 1983.
所以这是一个罕见的时刻，正如你所说，破例地在整个政治谱系中——除了极左翼人士之外，比如托尼·本恩（Tony Benn）、肯·利文斯顿（Ken Livingstone）、杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn）这样的人，以及阿瑟·斯卡吉尔（Arthur Scargill）——她获得了大量的赞誉。这种赞誉持续了多久才消退呢？持续了几天。不，我认为她有一段蜜月期，可能还会持续大约一年左右，实际上，大概一直持续到1983年夏季的连任胜利。
She definitely has been transformed in the public mind because she now is playing a role that she had never really played before. She has had sometimes sort of little stabs at playing it, example when bashing the europeans about the common market budget but she's now playing the role of the patriotic kind of national leader rather than the kind of the the nurse or the nanny administering medicine that you don't like but there's still i mean there's still that's still great on on people doesn't it because famously she wants to host a church service of celebration a kind of parade and and a church service in St. Paul's Cathedral. Yes. The Dean of St. Paul's is very much a man of the left.
她在公众心目中的形象确实发生了转变，因为她现在扮演了一个她以前从未真正扮演过的角色。她过去有时偶尔会尝试扮演这种角色，例如在共同市场预算问题上痛击欧洲人，但她现在扮演的是爱国主义式的国家领袖的角色，而不是那种发放大家不喜欢吃的苦药的护士或保姆的角色。但这种转变仍然——我的意思是，这仍然对人们产生了巨大的影响，对吧？因为众所周知，她希望举办一场庆祝性的教堂礼拜、一种游行，以及在圣保罗大教堂举行一场教堂礼拜。是的。圣保罗大教堂的院长是一个名副其实的左翼人士。
And he proposes that the service be done half in English and half in Spanish as a gesture of reconciliation with Argentina. And how does that go down with Mrs. Thatcher? Oh of course it's hilarious actually the discussions for this in the archives are brilliant because basically every churchman involved with it you know wants it to be utterly different from what she wants so she wants a national service of basically of thanksgiving God is in Englishman yeah the president of the Methodist conference says basically I don't want the slightest hint of celebration of our victory and no military men can read any lessons or do anything like that, you know, read any bits of the Bible.
他提议将礼拜仪式一半用英语、一半用西班牙语进行，以此作为与阿根廷人和解的姿态。撒切尔夫人对此作何反应？哦，当然这太滑稽了，其实档案中关于这事的讨论非常精彩，因为基本上所有参与其中的神职人员，你知道的，都希望它与她想要的完全不同。所以她想要一场基本上是感恩节的全国性礼拜——上帝是个英国人，对吧？卫理公会会议的主席基本上表示，我不希望有丝毫庆祝我们胜利的暗示，而且任何军人都不准宣读任何经文或做类似的事情，你知道的，宣读圣经的任何片断。
The Catholic Cardinal Basil Hume, he says he will not countenance any use of the word liberation of the Falklands in the service. And as you say, the Dean of St. Paul's, first of all, he wants half the service in Spanish. Mrs. Thatcher goes absolutely ballistic. And John Knott, our defense secretary, says, you know, the people who are inviting to this are the families of the dead. How are they going to react when they have to do the Lord's Prayer in Spanish?
天主教枢机主教巴斯尔·休姆（Basil Hume）表示，他绝不允许在礼拜仪式中使用“解放福克兰群岛”这个词。正如你所说，圣保罗大教堂的院长首先希望有一半的礼拜仪式使用西班牙语。撒切尔夫人简直气急败坏。我们的国防大臣约翰·诺特（John Knott）说，你知道的，被邀请参加这次活动的人是阵亡者的家属。当他们必须用西班牙语做主祷文时，他们会作何反应？
I mean, obviously they're not going to be very happy with that. So they basically whittle down the Dean of St. Paul. So at the end, he's basically reduced to saying, could we possibly at least print the Lord's Prayer in Spanish in the order of service? And Mrs. Thatcher just writes in the margin. No! Why?
我的意思是，显然他们对此不会很高兴。所以他们基本上把圣保罗大教堂的院长削弱到了这种地步：最后他基本上只能说，我们能不能至少在礼拜仪式程序单上把主祷文印成西班牙语？而撒切尔夫人在空白处直接写道：“不！为什么？”
So it doesn't happen. So it doesn't happen. But then what happens is the sermon is given by the Archbishop of Canterbury, Robert Runcie. So Robert Runcie, I mean, he's another of these. Yeah, absolutely. So he's another kind of thick glasses, gray hair, balding. He absolutely proves your point.
所以这没有发生。所以这没有发生。但随后发生的事情是，布道是由坎特伯雷大主教罗伯特·伦西（Robert Runcie）发表的。所以罗伯特·伦西，我的意思是，他是又一个这样的人。是的，绝对的。所以他又是那种厚眼镜、灰头发、秃顶的人。他完全证明了你的观点。
And he's an absolute war hero, isn't he? He was called Killer. He was a tank commander in the war. For those people who don't remember, and for overseas listeners, you think we've just gone mad. Robert Runcie is like a man that a casting agency would supply if you said, give me a wet, weedy, feeble, ineffectual churchman. Because his voice, everything about him exudes that.
而且他是个绝对的战争英雄，对吧？他被称为“杀手”。他在战争中是一名坦克指挥官。对于那些不记得的人以及海外听众来说，你们可能会觉得我们疯了。罗伯特·伦西就像是一个演员经纪公司会提供的那种人，如果你对他说：“给我找一个软弱无力、苍白无能的神职人员。”因为他的声音，他身上的每一处细节都散发着这种气质。
And yet, as you say, he'd been a tank commander in World War II who was called killer because of his- And he got FEC, didn't he? I mean, he was incredibly brave. The military cross, the military cross. I mean't he i mean he was incredibly brave military cross the military cross again i mean he's a very brave man to knock out three german gun emplacements under heavy fire and he gives this sermon where he says um he's thankful the war is over because it's impossible to be a christian and not to long for peace and he says all this sort of stuff um the
然而，正如你所说，他在二战中曾是一名坦克指挥官，因为他的——而且他获得了军功十字勋章，对吧？我的意思是，他极其勇敢。军功十字勋章，军功十字勋章。我的意思是——我的意思是，他极其勇敢，在猛烈炮火下摧毁了三个德国机枪阵地，而他发表的这篇布道说，呃，他很庆幸战争已经结束，因为作为基督徒不可能不渴望和平，他说了所有这些类似的话，呃，
deaths of so many young men is nothing to celebrate and of course we talked in the previous episode about the sun newspaper so the sun the day after that when they hear that they go absolutely mad and they call him the arch wimp of canterbury so this is kelvin mckenzie who has not taken out german gun emplacements or one no the mc no no no editorial backbencher sir john biggs davison says it is revolting for cringing clergy to misuse st paul's to throw doubt upon the sacrifice of our fighting men i don't know if he's knocked out german gun emplacements someday yeah but anyway yeah um but some but but actually the response to his sermon was quite positive wasn't it from people who'd
那么多年轻人的死亡没有什么值得庆祝的。当然，我们在上一集里谈到了《太阳报》，所以《太阳报》在听到这个消息的第二天简直气疯了，他们称他为“坎特伯雷的超级懦夫”。这就是凯尔文·麦肯齐（Kelvin McKenzie），他自己可没有去摧毁过德国机枪阵地，没有，没有。编辑部后座议员约翰·比格斯-戴维森（John Biggs-Davison）爵士说，畏缩的神职人员滥用圣保罗大教堂来对我们战斗人员的牺牲抛出质疑，这是令人作呕的。我不知道他有没有摧毁过德国机枪阵地，也许有一天吧。但不管怎样，呃，但是——但实际上，对于他的布道的反应相当不错，对吧，来自那些曾经——
attended uh yeah i mean it wasn't too cross about it. No, she makes a point of congratulating Runcie afterwards. And then it's later claimed as a bit of an urban myth, I think, that she thought it was awful. I think she was probably in an enervated state anyway because the arguments about whether there was going to be any Spanish. But certainly her cabinet ministers, so those other people who had served in World War II, thought it was great.
参加过的人——是的，我的意思是，她对这倒不是太生气。不，她特意在事后祝贺了伦西。后来有人宣称这有点像都市传说，我想，她当时觉得这糟透了。我想她当时大概也处于一种筋疲力尽的状态，因为关于是否会有西班牙语的争论。但毫无疑问，她的内阁大臣们，也就是那些曾在二战中服役过的人，认为这棒极了。
Willie Whitelaw, her sort of deputy, her cabinet ministers, so those other people who had served in World War II thought it was great. Willie Whitelaw, her sort of deputy, her home secretary, he says, I felt that he spoke exactly for me. His words were those of a soldier who understood what war is. And Mrs. Thatcher stands at the parade looking like the Queen. Yeah, so the parade is later in the year. They have a military parade through the city of London organized by the city. And she basically takes the salute of the army. There's also a dinner or a lunch or something
威利·怀特洛（Willie Whitelaw），她的某种副手，她的内阁大臣们——也就是那些曾在二战中服役过的人——认为这棒极了。威利·怀特洛，她的某种副手、内阁大臣兼内政大臣，他说：“我觉得他的话完全说出了我的心声。他的话是一个理解战争是什么样的军人所说的话。”撒切尔夫人在游行队伍中站着，看起来就像女王一样。是的，所以游行是在今年晚些时候进行的。伦敦市为他们组织了一场穿过伦敦市的军事游行。她基本上接受了军队的敬礼。还有一次晚宴或午餐什么的，
where she gets standing ovation from all the soldiers. I mean, she loves all this. She is absolutely Elizabeth I. It's her dream, of course. I mean, why wouldn't you? Winston. Yeah, she is Winston at this point. This is the thing. She was 13 years old, Tom, when World War II broke out.
她赢得了所有士兵起立鼓掌。我的意思是，她喜欢这一切。她绝对就是伊丽莎白一世。这当然是她的梦想。我的意思是，换作谁能不喜欢呢？温斯顿。是的，她此时就是温斯顿。就是这样。汤姆，二战爆发时她才13岁，
So very impressionable age. She worshipped Churchill. And she is absolutely playing the part of a sort of female Churchill who has defeated a fascist enemy, you know, all this sort of stuff. So absolutely she glories in this. Okay. So the electoral effect of this. Two questions. One from Stephenhen clark friend of the
所以正处于极易受影响的年龄。她崇拜丘吉尔。她绝对在扮演一种女丘吉尔的角色，击败了一个法西斯敌人，你知道的，诸如此类。所以她绝对为此感到荣耀。好的。那么这带来的选举效应呢。有两个问题。第一个来自史蒂芬·克拉克（Stephen Clark），他是节目的老朋友，
show yeah without the task force's liberation of the falkland islands would prime minister foot have been able to enact the policies listed in quote-unquote the longest suicide note in history so that's the labor manifesto of 1983 and benjaminon? Not the composer? Benjamin Bitton. That's a joke Dominic. Okay. It's an amusing pun. Okay sorry Benjamin. Did the war cost the SDP Liberal Alliance so that's the third party the centrist party that briefly had looked as though it might even become the government. Did it cost the SDP Liberal Alliance the 1983 general election and ensure at least 13 years of conservative rule or was that always going to happen given the split in the left of centre vote and the first-past-the-post electoral system? So I suppose basically what both those questions
是的。如果没有特遣舰队对福克兰群岛的解放，富特首相能够颁布列在所谓“历史上最长的自杀信”中的政策吗？也就是1983年的工党竞选宣言。还有本杰明·顿（Benjamin Bitton）？不是那个作曲家吧？本杰明·比特。这是个笑话，多米尼克。好吧。这是一个有趣的双关语。好吧，抱歉，本杰明。这场战争是否让社民党-自由党联盟——也就是第三党、中间派政党，一度看起来甚至可能成为政府——失去了1983年的大选，并确保了保守党至少13年的统治，还是说鉴于中左翼选票的分裂和领先者当选的选举制度，这本来就是不可避免的？所以我想基本上这两个问题
are asking... They're mutual exclusive questions though, aren't they? Well, they are kind of, but they're also kind of not, because essentially what they're asking is, did the Falklands War make a Conservative victory in the 1983 election inevitable? I mean, maybe the SDP would have won, maybe Labour would have won, but would the Conservatives definitely have lost had the Falklands War not happened? Okay, so I could spend hours talking about this, Tom. Well, you mustn't. Yeah. Five minutes.
都在问……但它们是互斥的问题，对吧？嗯，它们在某种程度上是，但它们在某种程度上又不是，因为本质上它们在问的是：马岛战争是否使得保守党在1983年大选中获胜成为不可避免的事情？我的意思是，也许社民党会赢，也许工党会赢，但如果没有发生马岛战争，保守党就一定会输吗？好吧，汤姆，我可以花几个小时谈论这个。好吧，你不能。好的。五分钟。
So the very short answer is, yes, it did make it inevitable but it was probably going to happen anyway the conservative victory so let's start with the labor the labor counterfactual steven clark's counterfactual michael foote when he became i mean you have heaped praise on michael foote in this podcast tom michael foote was a fantastically absurd person for the labor party to have chosen i just i just but I always love Michael Foote. As the leader of their party. But yes, he was. His poll ratings from the moment he became leader
所以简短的回答是：是的，这确实让它变得不可避免，但保守党的胜利无论如何也可能会发生。所以让我们从工党开始，工党的反事实，史蒂芬·克拉克的反事实。迈克尔·富特当他成为——我的意思是，汤姆，你在这个播客里对迈克尔·富特大加赞赏，迈克尔·富特对于工党来说是一个极度荒谬的领导人选择。我只是——我只是——但我一直很喜欢迈克尔·富特。作为他们党的领袖。但是是的，他是。他的民调支持率从他成为领袖的那一刻起
were absolutely abject. I mean, they were awful. And his party had been hideously divided in the course of 1981. I think we talked about this in our 1981 podcast, ripped apart by this sort of civil war between Tony Benn and Dennis Healey. And Foote
就绝对糟糕透顶。我的意思是，它们太糟糕了。而且在1981年的进程中，他的党派内部被恐怖地分裂了。我想我们在1981年的播客中谈到过这一点，被托尼·本恩和丹尼斯·希利（Denis Healey）之间的这种内战撕裂了。富特
struggled to impose his authority the public never ever showed the slightest sign of warming to him Labour of course went into the 1983 election very bitterly divided with the manifesto that a lot of its own MPs or candidates were uncomfortable with because they saw it as too left-wing I don't think there's any real – it's very hard to imagine a scenario in which Labour win an overall majority in 1983. As for the SDP-Liberal Alliance, again, how often do third parties rocket up in the polls in Britain and then just come crashing back down to earth, stymied by the electoral system, but also because their support
艰难地确立自己的权威。公众从来没有表现出哪怕一丝一毫对他产生好感的迹象。工党在1983年大选时自然是带着极度痛苦的分裂状态进入的，其竞选宣言甚至让许多工党自己的议员或候选人都感到不舒服，因为他们认为它太左翼了。我认为没有真正的——很难想象工党在1983年赢得压倒性多数议席的场景。至于社民党-自由党联盟，同样的，英国的第三党在民调中飙升然后又重重摔回地面这种情况有多频繁？它们受阻于选举制度，但也因为它们的支持率
is so soft, is a protest vote. And I think that's absolutely – I mean, the whole history of the SDP-Liberal Alliance suggests that that's the case. Now, did it, the argument is often, I said at the beginning, is it transformative? Because people often say, well, look, Thatcher was so unpopular before the war happened, and the Tories were third in the polls and all this sort of stuff. But what that misses is the sort of nuance, which is that the Tories had reached their nadir at the end of 1981 when the economy was in absolute doldrums,
非常脆弱，只是一种抗议投票。我认为这绝对是——我的意思是社民党-自由党联盟的整个历史都表明了这一点。那么，它——人们经常争论说，我一开始就说过，这具有变革性吗？因为人们经常说，看啊，在战争爆发之前撒切尔是多么不受欢迎，保守党在民调中排在第三位，诸如此类。但这种说法忽略了一种微妙之处，那就是保守党在1981年底经济陷入绝对低谷时达到了他们的最低谷，
but they were actually recovering in the early months of 1982. And is that because the economy was recovering? Because the economy was turning up, because basically interest rates were beginning to come down, consumer spending was going up. The worst, the terrible recession was largely… So that's 3 million unemployed. Well, I mean, it's still very high unemployment, but the worst of the terrible recession so that's three million unemployed well i mean it's still very high unemployment but the worst of the recession was so if you were in work if you're one of the nine out of ten people in work you were now having rising wages and you were spending more
但他们在1982年初其实已经在复苏了。这是因为经济在复苏吗？因为经济正在好转，因为基本上利率开始下降，消费者支出在增加。最糟糕的、可怕的经济衰退在很大程度上……所以那是300万失业人口。好吧，我的意思是，失业率仍然非常高，但最糟糕的、可怕的经济衰退——所以那是300万失业人口。好吧，我的意思是，失业率仍然非常高，但最糟糕的经济衰退——所以如果你有工作，如果你是十分之一有工作的人之一，你现在正在享受不断上涨的工资，并且花得更多
money so there's a big investigation to this in an article in the british journal of political science very detailed tons of graphs which i won't bore everybody with but they basically say what the falcons war does is it accelerates a tory recovery that probably would have happened anyway it may be it maybe accelerates it maybe accentuates it but i think that mrs thatcher was always going to win the 1983 election what obviously the war does is it provides a very good explanation for people who hate her why she why she did it you know because they she they think she's a monster and how on earth could the british people have voted for more of this awful medicine and the war becomes the explanation so um before we go to a break one last question from simon girdleston looking at the um the losers in the war yeah and he asks how important was the defeat in the
钱了。所以英国政治学杂志上的一篇文章对此进行了深入调查，非常详细，有大量的图表，我就不拿这些来烦大家了，但他们基本上说的是，马岛战争加速了保守党本无论如何都会发生的复苏。它可能加速了它，可能突显了它，但我认为撒切尔夫人无论如何都会赢得1983年的大选。这场战争显然所做到的是，它为那些讨厌她的人提供了一个极好的解释，解释她为什么要这样做，你知道的，因为他们认为她是个怪物，英国人民怎么可能投票支持更多这种可怕的苦药，而这场战争成了这个解释。所以，在我们休息之前，西蒙·格德尔斯顿（Simon Girdleston）提出了最后一个问题，他关注的是战争中的失败者，是的，他问：
falklands in bringing down the argentine military government the following year or was it likely to collapse anyway given the economic problems so that's basically the same question that we you've just answered um with regard to britain yeah apply to argentina uh well that's a really interesting question because most of those military regimes in South America were on a path towards democracy, but certainly by the end of the 1980s. So even Chile, actually, the Argentines' great rivals. But it probably would have happened later. Galtieri has to go straight away. So what happens to Galtieri?
马岛战败对次年推翻阿根廷军政府有多大重要性？或者鉴于经济问题，它本就会不可避免地崩溃？所以这基本上就是你刚刚回答的关于英国的那个问题，只不过应用到了阿根廷身上。嗯，这是一个非常有趣的问题，因为南美洲大多数这样的军政府都走在通往民主的道路上，到20世纪80年代末肯定如此。所以甚至连智利也是，实际上，那是阿根廷人的死对头。但这可能会晚些发生。加尔铁里（Galtieri）不得不立刻下台。那么加尔铁里发生了什么？
He goes to prison. Yes. So Galtieri resigns um almost immediately uh within days i mean he's basically removed from power by an internal you know the military spent a lot of time feuding in there looking for scapegoats so he then goes off to a sort of country estate for the next 18 months which actually isn't isn't a bad outcome for him you know i don't know what he's doing riding horses and drinking mulbeck or something and um but in about 83, he is charged with human rights violations, and he ends up
他入狱了。是的。所以加尔铁里几乎立刻辞职了，几天之内——他基本上是被内部推翻了，你知道的，军方花了很多时间在内部勾心斗角，寻找替罪羊。所以他在接下来的18个月里去了一个类似于乡村庄园的地方，这对他的结局来说其实不算太坏，你知道的，我不知道他在那里干什么，骑马、喝马尔贝克红酒（Malbec）什么的。而且，大约在83年，他被指控犯有侵犯人权罪，最后他
there's a whole series of court cases. He ends up being stripped of his rank, and then he's ended up being pardoned by Carlos Menem at the end of the 1980s. Carlos Menem's the guy with the huge cybers, isn't he? Massive cybers, yeah. So basically what happens is that Argentina, there are huge
经历了一系列法庭诉讼。他最终被剥夺了军衔，然后最终在20世纪80年代末被卡洛斯·梅内姆（Carlos Menem）特赦。卡洛斯·梅内姆就是那个留着巨大鬓角的人，对吧？巨大的鬓角，是的。所以基本上发生的情况是，阿根廷爆发了巨大的
public protests. I mean, the military junta had put all their eggs in this basket, basically, that they thought. It seems amazing they didn't supply more support then. But they couldn't. Because they didn't have it. Then they really had it. Fair enough. The British have knocked out part of Sports Standard's airfield.
公众抗议。我的意思是，军政府把所有的赌注都押在了这个筹码上，基本上他们认为——真让人惊讶，他们当时居然没有提供更多的支援。但他们做不到。因为他们没有。他们是真的没有。好吧。英国人摧毁了斯坦利港机场的一部分。
They just don't have all these extra supplies they can send. I mean, the amazing thing about the the the galtieri regime is that i mean i don't know whether one would like to think that there are parallels with vladimir putin or something there probably aren't but it'd be brilliant if there were because what they'd basically done was they just thought you know we'll go into the fulgham all their energy had been put into getting the islands, but defending the islands, it had never really occurred to them that the British would try to take them back. And they
他们只是没有所有这些可以派上用场的额外补给。我的意思是，加尔铁里政权最令人惊奇的地方在于——我的意思是，人们是否愿意认为这与弗拉基米尔·普京或类似的人有相似之处，可能没有，但如果有的话那就太棒了，因为他们基本上所做的就是他们只是想，你知道的，我们会进入福克兰——他们所有的精力都投入到了夺取岛屿上，但保卫岛屿，他们从来没有真正想过英国人会试图夺回它们。他们
thought, well, the Americans will side with us, so we don't even need to do any planning for fighting off an invasion. So when the invasion happens, they're a bit rabbit in the headlines. I mean, there's a real sort of they actually fight, some of them fight, particularly the pilots, fight very kind of of valiantly but it's an absolute losing cause i mean they were probably you know as long as as long as luck didn't really go against the british
认为，嗯，美国人会站在我们这边，所以我们甚至不需要做任何击退入侵的计划。所以当入侵发生时，他们有点像惊吓过度的兔子。我的意思是，确实有一种——他们实际上进行了战斗，其中一些人战斗得非常英勇，特别是飞行员，进行了非常英勇的战斗，但这是一场绝对必输的战役，我的意思是，他们可能——你知道的，只要运气没有真正背离英国人，
the argentines were always in a real sort of uphill struggle okay and so you um an argentina does become it to repeat Simon's question, does it expedite the process? Yeah, it does speed it up. Absolutely speeds it up. Yeah, because the junta is completely and utterly discredited. Their dream was to recapture the Falklands. They'd done it and they were absolutely campaigning on it.
阿根廷人始终处于一场真正的艰难挣扎中。好的，所以你——而阿根廷确实成为了——重复西蒙的问题，这是否催化了这个进程？是的，它确实加速了。绝对加速了。是的，因为军政府已经彻底名誉扫地了。他们的梦想是重新夺回福克兰群岛。他们做到了，并且一直在为此大肆宣传。
And then for everything to blow up as disastrous as it did, they've got nothing left. They've got nothing to, they stand for nothing. And that Borges quote that you began the whole series with, two bald men quarreling over a comb, is that how it comes to be seen, that it was a pointless war? In Argentina? Yeah.
然后一切都像那样灾难性地炸裂了，他们什么都没剩下。他们什么都没有了，一无所有。而你在整个系列开头引用的博尔赫斯的那句话——“两个秃子在为一把梳子争吵”，事情最终就是这样被看待的吗？认为这是一场毫无意义的战争？在阿根廷？是的。
No, I don't, certainly not on the kind of right of Argentine politics. I mean, I think a lot of people on the right would just say, I mean, there'd be some people who would say, they're still at our islands. You know, we still want them back. And one day we'll get them. Maybe they will. Well, maybe they will.
不，我不这么认为，在阿根廷右翼政治中绝对不是这样。我的意思是，我认为右翼的许多人会说，我的意思是，会有一些人说，那仍然是我们的岛屿。你知道，我们仍然想要回它们。总有一天我们会得到的。也许他们会吧。好吧，也许他们会。
I mean, who knows? Well, so that takes us on to the broader perspective. We've got, again, lots of questions about that. So let's take a break. And when we come back, we will finish off this series by looking at some of those broad brush questions about that. So let's take a break. And when we come back, we will finish off this series by looking at some of those broad brush questions. Okay.
我的意思是，谁知道呢？好吧，这就把我们带向了更广阔的视角。我们再次收到了很多关于这方面的问题。所以我们休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将通过探讨一些关于这方面的大而化之的问题来结束本系列。所以我们休息一下。当我们回来时，我们将通过探讨一些大而化之的问题来结束本系列。好的。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的固定阵地。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、番外节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
We hope you've enjoyed our retelling of the Falklands over these last three and a half episodes and we'll get back to the final part very shortly. But before we do that, I just wanted to let you know about a new series from our producers, also on the Falklands War. It's called Battleground, and it's hosted by the military historian Saul David and the foreign correspondent Patrick Bishop, who was actually on board one of the British ships during the campaign. Basically, if our version has wet your whistle, but you prefer your history with more on the battles and maybe slightly fewer genius impersonations, then this is the pod for you. And every episode, they're going to be talking
希望大家喜欢我们在过去三个半集里对马岛战争的重新讲述，我们很快就会回到最后一部分。但在我们这样做之前，我只想向大家介绍我们制作人制作的一档新节目，同样是关于马岛战争的。它叫做《战场》（Battleground），由军事历史学家索尔·大卫（Saul David）和战地记者帕特里克·主教（Patrick Bishop）主持，他在战役期间实际上就在其中一艘英国军舰上。基本上，如果我们的版本勾起了你的兴趣，但你更喜欢关于战役的更多细节、或许稍微少一点天才模仿秀的历史，那么这就是为你量身打造的播客。每一集，他们都会与亲历核心行动的人进行交谈，
to someone who was at the heart of the action, from special forces commandos, to military leaders, to politicians. In the first episode, it's Lord Luce, the Foreign Office Minister responsible for the islands, who led the diplomatic effort before the invasion and was in the room for some of the dramatic decisions made by Mrs Thatcher and others that we've talked about here on our series. Search for Battleground, The Falklands War, wherever you get your podcasts, or there's a link in the episode description. Hello, welcome back to the final part of our Falklands War epic.
从特种部队突击队员，到军事领袖，再到政治家。在第一集里，嘉宾是负责该群岛的外交部大臣露丝勋爵（Lord Luce），他在入侵前领导了外交努力，并且亲历了我们在本系列中讨论过的撒持尔夫人和其他人做出的一些戏剧性决策。在获取播客的任何地方搜索《战场：马岛战争》（Battleground, The Falklands War），或者点击剧集简介中的链接。哈喽，欢迎回到我们的马岛战争史诗的最后一部分。
Dominic, we're going to look, pull the camera back now, look at, well, basically, I mean, this is quite an important question bearing in mind we've spent you know hours almost discussing this we have been here all day so did it actually matter um you know it doesn't have any kind of broad significance so for starters from liam cj97 what significance if any did the falklands war have regarding the broader cold war context in which it took place so specifically the cold war the cold war i think it's um
多米尼克，我们将把镜头拉远，审视——好吧，基本上，我的意思是，考虑到我们已经花了数小时几乎在讨论这个，这是一个相当重要的问题，我们今天一整天都在这儿——所以它到底重要吗？你知道的，它有什么广泛的意义吗？首先，来自Liam_cj97的问题：马岛战争对于它所发生的更广泛的冷战背景有什么意义（如果有的话）？具体来说是冷战，冷战，我认为这是……
because it's it's too you know in terms of the cold war it's two allies fighting with one another which is why it was so difficult for america funny thing about the cold war context is that um much of the british public debate during the early weeks of the war among the public themselves has a Cold War dimension. So the number of people who are recorded in mass observation is going at this point, which is this sort of project where people send in. You can just still do it now, actually. It's a brilliant historical project. And all listeners should do it. You send in, you know, you write about what's going on in your life
因为它是——你知道的，就冷战而言，这是两个盟友之间的内讧，这就是为什么这对美国来说如此棘手。关于冷战背景的一个有趣之处在于，呃，在战争头几周的公众讨论中，英国公众之中的许多讨论其实具有冷战维度。所以在大众观察（Mass Observation）中记录下来的人数当时正在增加，这是一个人们发送信件的项目。你现在其实仍然可以这样做。这是一个出色的历史项目。所有听众都应该去做。你发送，你知道的，写下你生活中正在发生的事情，
takes and you're hot yeah and what's going on what you've heard people say and how you're like so there's a resource for future historians and the mass observers sometimes record people saying we have to go in because the russians will go in next or they say if we don't fight to to get the falcons back now the russians will be in the isle of wight tomorrow yeah or the channel island so so people see it in that context i think the russians they are impressed with the british fighting spirit and with mrs thatcher but also slightly contemptuous of it as a an imperialist no well they're sort of obviously in public they say it's an imperialist venture and all this sort of stuff but i think they think it's, if they think about it at all, they think the British actually fought much more,
你的真实想法，还有你听到了别人说什么，以及你如何——所以这是为未来的历史学家准备的资源。大众观察员有时会记录到人们说：“我们必须介入，否则俄罗斯人会紧接着介入”；或者他们说：“如果我们现在不为夺回马岛而战，俄罗斯人明天就会踏上怀特岛（Isle of Wight）或海峡群岛（Channel Islands）。”所以人们是从这个背景来看待它的。我认为俄罗斯人对英国人的战斗精神和撒切尔夫人印象深刻，但同时也对它作为一种帝国主义行为略带轻蔑——
showed much more spirit than we would expect and they're not to be taken lightly. And certainly the other Western allies, so the parts of the Western allies like, say, France, Canada and so on, I mean, they bombard Mr. Stature with private messages afterwards saying, what an amazing achievement. You know, you've done so well. We really admire what you've done, all this sort of stuff.
不，好吧，他们在公开场合说这是一场帝国主义冒险，诸如此类，但我认为他们认为——如果他们真的去想这件事的话，他们认为英国人实际上打得顽强得多，表现出的精神远超我们的预期，这是不容小觑的。当然，其他西方盟友，西方盟友的各个部分，比如法国、加拿大等等，我的意思是，他们在事后用私信狂轰滥炸撒切尔夫人，说这是一项多么了不起的成就。你知道的，你们干得太棒了。我们由衷地钦佩你们所做的一切，诸如此类。
But actually, in terms of did it affect the outcome of the Cold War? No, not at all. Not at all. Okay. Is there a case to be made for its broader significance then in other terms? Yeah. So when we started the podcast in the very first episode,
但实际上，就它是否影响了冷战的结果而言？完全没有。完全没有。好吧，那么从其他角度来看，是否有理由说明其更广泛的意义呢？是的。所以当我们在这个播客的第一集开始时，
we talked about three different places three different groups of people the Falkland Islands Argentina and Britain and it mattered enormously for all three
我们谈到了三个不同的地方、三群不同的人：福克兰群岛、阿根廷和英国，这对这三者来说都极其重要。
so let's do Argentina first I mean we talked about at the end of the last episode for Argentina it is the nail in the coffin of the of the junta
所以我们先说阿根廷。我的意思是，我们在上一集的结尾谈到过，对阿根廷来说，这是军政府棺材上的最后一颗钉子。
they probably would have fallen at some point anyway because of the general trend towards democratization in Latin America, but it speeded that up. It utterly discredited the military regime. So it obviously had an immediate impact on Argentine politics.
由于拉丁美洲普遍的民主化趋势，他们无论如何可能在某个时候垮台，但这场战争加速了这一进程。它彻底使军政府名誉扫地。所以它显然对阿根廷政治产生了直接的影响。
It's a colossal moment in recent... I mean, how many wars has Argentina fought in the last 100 or 150 years? Not that many. So it's a massive moment for them. For the Falkland Islanders, now this is where the Borges analogy, I think, falls down. The two bald men fighting over a comb.
这是近代历史上一个巨大的时刻……我的意思是，在过去的一百年或一百五十年里，阿根廷打过多少次仗？没几次。所以这对他们来说是一个巨大的时刻。对于福克兰群岛居民来说，现在这就是博尔赫斯类比失效的地方，我认为。两个秃子为一把梳子争吵。
Because the Falkland Islanders are not a comb. I mean, they would say we're a community. Now, there are some people around Mrs. Thatcher who said, bribe them. Just pay them. So that's Alan Walters. Alan Walters, yeah. He talked about it in the first episode.
因为福克兰群岛居民不是一把梳子。我的意思是，他们会说我们是一个社群。现在，撒切尔夫人身边有一些人说：贿赂他们。直接付钱给他们。所以那是艾伦·沃尔特斯（Alan Walters）。艾伦·沃尔特斯，是的。他在第一集里谈到了这一点。
Pay them to move, you know. I mean, there were sort of people in the... Because it's so expensive to look after. Because it's too expensive to look after them. And it's too expensive to fight to get them back. Just in the same way that there were people, sort of letter writers to the Guardian in 1982 who said, who cares what they think?
付钱让他们搬走，你知道的。我的意思是，在……因为照顾他们太昂贵了。因为照顾他们太昂贵了。而且为了夺回他们而进行战争的代价也太高了。就像1982年《卫报》的一些读者写信说的那样：谁在乎他们怎么想？
You know, bring them back, give them farms in Scotland or something. I think that's a pretty odd position to take, that everyone gets self-determination except the Falkland Islanders. I mean, clearly the Falkland Islanders did not want to be part of Argentina. They didn't want the Argentine military regime in charge of them. It seems, I mean, they'd been invaded. It seems odd to say that you wouldn't, that their interests are insignificant. And to reiterate, in terms of fashioning a war that makes Britain look as good as possible, the Falklands War is about as good as it gets because, as you said, there are no people who are being oppressed by the Falkland Islanders they've they've lived
你知道的，把他们带回来，在苏格兰给他们分配农场什么的。我认为这是一种相当奇特的立场，即每个人都享有自决权，唯独福克兰群岛居民没有。我的意思是，很显然福克兰群岛居民并不想成为阿根廷的一部分。他们不希望阿根廷军政府统治他们。这似乎——我的意思是，他们遭到了入侵。说你不会去理会他们的利益，说他们的利益微不足道，这似乎很奇怪。再重申一遍，就塑造一场让英国看起来尽可能完美的战争而言，马岛战争可以说是无以复加的好，因为正如你所说，没有人遭到福克兰群岛居民的压迫，他们在那里生活了
there for generation after generation um the people who invade are kind of torturers they're fascists it's insofar as a British war can shed the kind of imperial baggage yeah the Falklands war is actually as unimperial as or at least as uncolonial as you as you like to get defending a British colonial territory let's get to I mean two people there are two objections that might be made to what you just said Tom or to what I mean I agree with you but there are two objections what objection number one might be well the islands should be Argentine anyway because they were Spanish before that but it's very telling that neither Britain nor Argentina has ever referred the case really gone for referring the case to an international court spain has never well maybe spain or indeed france or did french i mean they all and the reason the british
一代又一代，呃，入侵的人是一群折磨者、法西斯分子。就一场英国战争能够摆脱那种帝国主义包袱而言，马岛战争实际上是尽可能不属于帝国主义性质的——或者至少是不殖民主义性质的，它保卫的是一个英国殖民地领土。让我们来谈谈——我的意思是，对你刚才所说的话或者我的意思——我同意你的看法，但可能会有人提出两个反对意见，汤姆。反对意见一可能是：嗯，这些岛屿无论如何都应该是阿根廷的，因为在此之前它们属于西班牙。但非常说明问题的是，英国和阿根廷从未真正将案件提交给国际法院。西班牙从来没有——也许西班牙，或者确实法国，或者法国——我的意思是，他们都——英国人和阿根廷人之所以没有这样做，是因为双方都没有完全确信
and argentines haven't done it is because neither is completely convinced of the that they'd win that they'd win um but but equally it just it does seem weird to i mean the the islands nobody there speaks, they don't speak Spanish, they don't have cultural links with Argentina. The Argentine claim, which is based on a kind of propinquity, I suppose, that they're only 500 miles away,
自己能赢，自己能赢。但是，但同样，这确实显得很奇怪——我的意思是，岛上没有人说西班牙语，他们与阿根廷没有文化联系。阿根廷的主张是基于一种邻近性，我想，即它们只有500英里远，
is pure nationalism, really. I mean, it's pure nationalism. So that would be my counter to the 1833, they should have been always Argentine argument. The other argument is that, oh, the British are just imperialists it's a legacy of empire and britain shouldn't have it but of course the problem with that is well if if the british are just imperialists and their falklands is just a colonial relic what's argentina yeah i mean yeah i mean all the argentines have spanish or italian they don't have indigenous, you know, sort of pre-Columbian conquest surnames.
这其实纯粹是民族主义。我的意思是，这纯粹是对1833年“它们本该永远属于阿根廷”这一论点的反驳。另一个论点是：“哦，英国人只是帝国主义者，这是帝国的遗产，英国不应该拥有它们。”但当然，这其中的问题在于：好吧，如果英国人只是帝国主义者，福克兰群岛只是一处殖民遗迹，那阿根廷算什么？我的意思是，所有的阿根廷人都拥有西班牙或意大利血统，他们没有土著的，你知道的，前哥伦布时期征服的姓氏。
They're all Spanish and Italian, European surnames because they all have Spanish and Italian heritage. Oh, indeed. Or German or Welsh. No, Fairpoint, well-made. Well, lots of Welsh, aren't there? In Patagonia. Patagonia, yeah.
他们全都是西班牙和意大利的欧洲姓氏，因为他们都有西班牙和意大利血统。哦，确实。或者德国或威尔士血统。好吧，说得对，言之有理。有很多威尔士人，对吧？在巴塔哥尼亚。巴塔哥尼亚，是的。
With the dinosaurs. Maybe the Welsh. So dinosaurs and Welsh people. Maybe the Falklands should be a colony of a greater Welsh empire. Yeah. I'll tell you what distracted me, Tom, there. There's a series of books.
还有恐龙。也许威尔士人——所以恐龙和威尔士人。也许福克兰群岛应该成为大威尔士帝国的一个殖民地。是的。我告诉你是什么让我分心了，汤姆，那里有一系列书。
Have you ever read a series of books by a guy called Malcolm Price? No. They're called Aberystwyth, Mon Amour, Last Tango and Aberystwyth and so on. No. They're sort of noir fiction set in Aberystwyth in Wales. Really? And they're in a weird parallel universe where Wales had a colony where Argentina was Welsh.
你读过一个叫马尔科姆·普赖斯（Malcolm Price）的人写的一系列书吗？没有。它们叫《阿伯里斯特威斯，我的爱》（Aberystwyth, Mon Amour）、《最后的探戈在阿伯里斯特威斯》（Last Tango in Aberystwyth）等等。没有。它们是设定在威尔士阿伯里斯特威斯的黑色小说。真的吗？它们发生在一个奇怪的平行宇宙中，在那个宇宙里，威尔士曾拥有过一个殖民地，而那个地方就是阿根廷，那里的阿根廷人是威尔士人。
Oh, right. Oh, I must read it. Yeah, it's very good. They're very good. I'd say like Prince Madoc, who is supposed to have colonized North America in the Middle Ages. Is that right? Yeah.
哦，对。我得读读。是的，非常棒。它们非常不错。我想就像马多克王子（Prince Madoc）一样，据说他在中世纪殖民了北美。是这样吗？是的。
Oh, that's good. So there are scholars who think that there are traces of the welsh language in various native american i'm dubious about that yeah i i let's say the scholarly consensus isn't entirely behind that okay argument but it but it's it's there anyway listen we are again yeah it is it is so here here is um a question from diogo mogado again very much friend of the show um dominic suggested that had britain lost the war it wouldn't think of itself as a major world power and hence brexit would never have happened what i love about that your your your your your your hot brexit take he is familiar
哦，那太好了。所以有些学者认为威尔士语在各种美洲原住民语言中留下了痕迹，我对这一点持怀疑态度，好吧，我是说，学术界并没有完全支持那个观点，好吧，不过，不管怎样，它确实存在，听着，我们又来了，对，确实如此，所以这里是迪奥戈·莫加多（Diogo Mogado）的一个问题，同样也是节目的老朋友，多米尼克曾表示，如果英国输掉了战争，它就不会把自己视为一个主要的世界大国，因此英国脱欧也就永远不会发生，我最喜欢你那个关于脱欧的惊人观点了，他很熟悉
with my thesis he is familiar with my thesis yes so why it matters for britain i think is not because it ensures mrs thatcher another term because i think she'd have had that anyway why i think it really matters for britain is that really since suez so you mentioned suez when we're talking about the commons meeting the aftermath of the argentine invasion and you were putting up then weren't you putting up the net in your garden that's right yeah the cricket net um and this being a great moment of national humiliation and the funny thing about that was that was absolutely the kind of thing that you'd expect to happen in britain because in many ways the story of the last few decades had been one of perceived national humiliation so the loss of of all the different bits empire, Union Jacks coming around in places across the world,
我的论点，他很熟悉我的论点，是的，所以为什么这对英国很重要，我认为并不是因为它确保了撒切尔夫人的又一个任期，因为我认为她本来也会得到的，为什么我认为它对英国真正重要的是，其实自苏伊士运河事件以来——所以当你提到苏伊士运河时，我们在谈论下议院的会议，阿根廷入侵之后的余波，当时你不是在建网吗，你在花园里搭网对吧，没错，是的，板球网，呃，这成为了国家屈辱的巨大时刻，而有趣的是，这绝对是那种你预料会在英国发生的事情，因为在许多方面，过去几十年的历史一直是一个被认为遭受国家屈辱的历史，所以失去了
the horrible saga of Northern Ireland, which is a terrible sort of stain on Britain's international reputation in the 70s and 80s, rightly or wrongly, but also economic sort of embarrassments, the devaluation of the pound, having to get a bailout from the International Monetary Fund, all these kinds of things. This sort of perception of Britain as the sick man of Europe.
帝国的所有不同部分，世界各地许多地方的英国国旗纷纷降下，北爱尔兰那场可怕的风波，在70年代和80年代，这可以说是英国国际声誉的一个巨大污点，不管对错，还有经济上的种种难堪，英镑贬值，不得不接受国际货币基金组织的救助，所有这些诸如此类的事情。这种将英国视为“欧洲病夫”的看法。
So when the Falklands War happens, to me, I think that sort of sets the seal on all that. And that moment that you ventriloquize so splendidly where Sir Henry Leach says to Mrs Thatcher, if we don't fight, we shall be living in an entirely different country. Shall I do it again? Do you want to? Yeah, would you like to hear it again?
所以当马岛战争发生时，对我来说，我认为这基本上给这一切盖棺定论了。而那个你模仿得如此精彩的时刻，亨利·里奇爵士（Sir Henry Leach）对撒切尔夫人说，如果我们不战，我们将生活在一个完全不同的国家里。要我再演一遍吗？你想听吗？对，你想再听一遍吗？
I mean, I think the listeners would have found it very moving. I can only guess what the listeners will be thinking when they come to listen to this, but maybe they will want it again? Do you want to? Yeah, would you like to hear it again? I mean, I think the listeners would have found it very moving. I can only guess what the listeners will be thinking when they come to listen to this, but maybe they will want it again. Yeah, let's reprise it. Go on then. Can we do it? Yes, we can, Prime Minister. And though it is not my business to say so, we must.
我的意思是，听众们一定会觉得非常感人。我只能猜测听众们在收听这个节目时会怎么想，但也许他们会想再听一次？你想吗？对，你想再听一遍吗？我的意思是，听众们一定会觉得非常感人。我只能猜测听众们在收听这个节目时会怎么想，但也许他们会想再听一次。好吧，让我们重演一遍。那就来吧。我们能做到吗？是的，我们能，首相。尽管这不是我该说的话，但我们必须这么做。
For if we do not, or if we pussyfoot in our actions and do not achieve complete success, in another few months we shall be living in a totally different country or if we pussyfoot in our actions and do not achieve complete success, in another few months, we shall be living in a totally different country whose word will count for little. Now, you see, Tom, I think you delivered it this time with more feeling. I did. Because?
因为如果我们不这样做，或者我们在行动中畏首畏尾，未能取得彻底的成功，再过几个月，我们将生活在一个完全不同的国家里，或者如果我们行动畏首畏尾，未能取得彻底的成功，再过几个月，我们将生活在一个完全不同的国家里，它的言论将无足轻重。现在你看，汤姆，我觉得你这次的演绎更有感情了。我是有。因为？
I did, because we've reached the end. And so now I'm- Because before you didn't know what was going to happen. No, now I'm aflame with patriotic zeal. Yeah, because you didn't know how it was going to end. The Union Jack is'm aflame with patriotic zeal. Yeah, because you didn't know how it was going to end. The Union Jack is fluttering over my head
我是有，因为我们已经到了结尾。所以现在我——因为之前你不知道会发生什么。不，现在我充满了爱国热情。对，因为你不知道它会如何结局。米字旗正——我充满了爱国热情。对，因为你不知道它会如何结局。米字旗在飘扬
as I recite that. Extraordinary scenes at Brixton. So, yes, so Henry Leach's argument that basically it's a turning point, he says,
当我背诵这段话时。布里克斯顿的非凡场景。所以，是的，所以亨利·里奇的论点基本上是一个转折点，他说，
if we don't do this, I think is an interesting one. What if they hadn't done it? What if they had allowed, you know, the Argentines as it were to get away with it? Or what if they had sent the task force andines were to get away with it or what if
如果我们不这样做，我觉得这是一个很有趣的问题。如果他们没有这么做呢？如果他们，你知道的，任由阿根廷人得逞呢？或者如果他们派遣了特遣舰队——阿根廷人得逞了，或者如果他们
they had sent the task force and they had blown out of the sea and be blown out of the sea what would have happened then well irrespective of the political impact i think psychologically what that would have done would it was it it would have confirmed the narrative that was so entrenched in the 1970s of inevitable british decline of britain as the kind of market leader in a kind of in being a failing western democracy yeah and also I suppose a specific you know confined to the European theatre because oh absolutely absolutely you know the whole sending ships across the across the ocean but also Diogo Morgaro's argument which is that um well I think it's your argument isn't it that he's yeah it is so so the thing about
派遣了特遣舰队，结果却被轰出海面，被轰出海面，那接下来会发生什么呢？好吧，抛开政治影响不谈，我认为从心理上讲，这会证实20世纪70年代根深蒂固的那种叙事，即英国不可避免的衰落，英国作为一种失败的西方民主国家中的市场领先地位的代表，是的，而且我也认为这是一个特定的，你知道的，局限于欧洲战场的——哦，绝对是，绝对是，你知道的，派遣船只跨越大洋的整个举措，还有迪奥戈·莫加多的观点，也就是，嗯，我想这也是你的观点，对吧，他是——是的，确实是，所以，关于
brexit and the thing about europe's specifically britain had gone into europe in 1973 and and there were really i mean there had been a bit of the element of like we're all friends now after the war let's join hands kind of come by our but probably a stronger sense in that debate was we were an empire and we're not anymore. So we have to kind of find a new lifeboat to jump into. So this sort of people have gone into Europe quite, the public polls show people, a lot of people have gone into Europe quite grudgingly as a sort of a strategy born of a perceived sense of failure. And what you absolutely see everywhere in the summer of 1982, you see it in the press, you see it in people's diaries,
脱欧以及特别是关于欧洲的事情，英国是在1973年加入欧洲的，而且确实——我的意思是，战后曾经有过那么一点“我们现在都是朋友了，让我们手拉手来吧”的元素，但那场辩论中可能更强烈的一种感觉是：我们曾经是个帝国，而现在不再是了。所以我们必须寻找一个新的救生艇跳进去。因此，这种人们满腹牢骚地加入欧洲的心态，民意调查显示，很多人加入欧洲是非常勉强的，这是一种源于对失败感认知的策略。而你在1982年夏天的各个地方绝对都能看到这一点，你在报纸上能看到，你在人们的日记里能看到，
you see it on TV. You know, ITV has this huge night of spectacular with all Roger Moore and I don't know, Shawody, whatever. And from that point on, Brexit was inevitable. But there's this sort of sense, Britain has changed. Britain has become a different kind of country. And Mrs. Thatcher, absolutely. I'm just trying to dig out the...
你在电视上也能看到。你知道，ITV（独立电视台）有一个盛大的演出之夜，有罗杰·摩尔（Roger Moore）和，我不知道，还有查蒂（Shawaddywaddy）什么的。从那一刻起，脱欧就成了不可避免的。但有这样一种感觉，英国变了。英国已经变成了一个不同类型的国家。撒切尔夫人，绝对是的。我只是在试图找出……
Well, here's a good example. So this is from the Daily Express. The columnist who wrote this, I met him after I'd published the book, and he said he was delighted that I'd dug out his column and featured it. It's a guy got Peter Mackay. Here is a column called The Crowning Glory.
好吧，这里有一个很好的例子。所以这摘自《每日快报》。写下这篇文章的专栏作家，在我出版了这本书后我遇到了他，他说他很高兴我翻出了他的专栏并加以引用。这是一个叫彼得·麦凯（Peter Mackay）的人。这里有一个名为《加冕的荣耀》的专栏。
And this is after Princess Diana gave birth a week after the end of the Falklands War to Prince William. What times we live in, the excitement surrounding a royal birth, the famous victory in the Falklands, a nation which according to all recent opinion polls exalts in a common aim. There cannot have been a June like this for 30 years indeed since june 1953 the queen's coronation coinciding with the conquering of everest and the headline over both events which said all this and everest too he goes on he says we'll have to wait for a long time to see the likes of this summer and the excitement of these days,
这是在戴安娜王妃在马岛战争结束一周后生下威廉王子之后写的。我们生活在怎样的时代啊，皇室诞生带来的兴奋，马岛之役的著名胜利，一个根据最近所有民意调查显示都拥有共同目标的国家。30年来，甚至自从1953年6月女王加冕礼与征服珠穆朗玛峰巧合以来，还从没有过这样的六月。而这两个事件的头条新闻写着：“这一切，还有珠穆朗玛峰！”他接着说道，我们要等很长时间才能看到像今年夏天这样令人兴奋的日子，
days in which we seem incapable of defeat and that kind of stuff, which Mrs. Thatcher does too. She goes to Cheltenham race course and she gives this speech saying, um, we have ceased to be a nation in retreat. We have found ourselves again in the folklore. It's the spirit of the South Atlantic, as she calls it. Enoch Powell, who people sometimes see
在这些日子里，我们似乎不可战胜，诸如此类的话，撒切尔夫人也是这么说的。她去切尔滕纳姆赛马场发表了这样一篇演讲，她说，嗯，我们不再是一个撤退的国家。我们在民间传说中重新找到了自我。这就是她所说的南大西洋精神。伊诺克·鲍威尔（Enoch Powell），有时被人们视为
as one of the prophets of Thatcherism, he wrote in his book, he said, a change has come about in Britain. We are ourselves again. And that kind of, I mean, that was the title, as you know, Tom, of the final chapter of my book on this, We Are Ourselves Again. Because I think among people of that persuasion, because I think among people of that persuasion,
撒切尔主义的先知之一，他在书中写道，英国发生了一种变化。我们重新找回了自己。而这种——我的意思是，正如你所知道的，汤姆，那正是我关于此事的书的最后一章的标题：“我们重新找回了自己”。因为我认为在持有这种信念的人当中，因为我认为在持有这种信念的人当中，
not everybody, but people of that persuasion, there's this sense of, oh, thank God we've thrown off the last few decades. We're an exceptional country with an unrivaled past and a unique destiny. And the whole, you know, now the European project gets in the way of that. Despite the fact, of course, as we know, the French helped us. Yeah. Chileans helped us. The United States helped us.
并非所有人，但持有这种信念的人，会有这样一种感觉：哦，谢天谢地，我们已经摆脱了过去的几十年。我们是一个拥有无与伦比的过去和独特命运的杰出国家。而整个——你知道的，现在欧洲项目挡了道。尽管事实上，当然，正如我们所知，法国人帮助了我们。是的。智利人帮助了我们。美国人帮助了我们。
We didn't do it all alone. But the alone myth becomes absolutely embedded from this point onwards. Can I just, I mean, two possible objections to that. Yeah, go for it. One is that between the Falklands and the brexit vote you have the iraq war in which britain is you know a junior player in a disastrous war yeah uh does that not kind of and and again is revisiting a kind of a scene of of the colonial past in the in the form of iraq yeah but i don't think the Iraq war, I mean...
我们并非全靠自己孤军奋战。但“孤军奋战”的神话从这一刻起变得根深蒂固。我能不能——我是说，对此有两个可能的反对意见。好的，尽管说。一是，在马岛战争和脱欧公投之间，你还有伊拉克战争，英国在其中——你知道的——是一场灾难性战争中的次要参与者，是的，呃，这难道没有——并且这再次重现了——以伊拉克的名义——殖民过去的场景吗？是的，但我不认为伊拉克战争，我的意思是……
Does that not kind of have a knock-on? I mean, I think it definitely does. Does it change the way people think about Britain? Well, I think it... It changes the way people think about Tony Blair, your pal Tony Blair, but it doesn't change the... Well, I mean, so support for the... You said that support for the Falklands War
这难道没有产生连锁反应吗？我的意思是，我认为绝对有。这难道不会改变人们对英国的看法吗？嗯，我认为它……它改变了人们对托尼·布莱尔的看法，你的好朋友托尼·布莱尔，但它并没有改变……嗯，我是说，所以对于……你曾说过，对于马岛战争的支持
in the wake of the war was kind of 80%, 80-20%. The Brexit vote was 52-48. So that implies that there's been quite a decline in the sense of Britain as a go-it-alone, have-a-go hero kind of country. And I would say that the experience of Britain going to war in distant non-European theatres hasn't been a particularly glorious one since the Falklands. Yeah, that's true. I mean, obviously Iraq and Afghanistan and so on. But I don't think those conflicts are as –
在战争结束后大约是80%，80%-20%。而脱欧公投是52%-48%。所以这意味着，人们将英国视为一个独行侠式、敢作敢为的英雄国家的这种感觉已经有了相当大的下降。而且我想说的是，自马岛战争以来，英国介入遥远非欧洲战场的战争经历并不是一段特别光彩的经历。是的，这倒也是。我的意思是，显然有伊拉克、阿富汗等等。但我不认为这些冲突——
so what the Falklands, I think, is, is it's the sort of missing link in a way between them the the world war ii myth if you like nation standing alone summer 1940 churchill all that i mean when i say myth i don't mean it's invented but i mean it's taken on the quality of the mythic mythic resonance mythic resonance it's i think it's the it's the sort of the thread the staging post there's two different metaphors anyway it's one of them. Between 1940 and 2016. So this idea that Britain can do things, that it's refound itself, the flying of not much of that patriotic populism in the 60s and 70s. There's actually a much wider sense of kind of defeatism, constant publishing of league tables in which Britain's at the bottom. And after 1982, the speed with which that vanishes from the national discourse is extraordinary.
所以马岛战争，我认为，它是二战神话之间某种缺失的环节，如果你愿意这么说的话——国家孤立无援、1940年夏天、丘吉尔、所有这些——我的意思是，当我提到神话时，我并不是指它是虚构的，而是指它具有了神话般的品质、神话般的共鸣、神话般的共鸣。我认为它是——它是一种线索、中继站（抱歉，用了两个不同的隐喻）。总之，它是其中的一个。在1940年和2016年之间。所以这种认为英国能够成就伟业、它已经重新找到了自我的想法——在60年代和70年代，并没有太多这种爱国平民主义。实际上，当时存在着一种更广泛的失败主义情绪，排行榜上不断公布英国垫底的排名。而1982年之后，这种情绪从国家话语中消失的速度是惊人的。
And I think, okay, you can't draw, it's not a simple direct line between 1982 and 2016 but if 1982 had worked out differently i mean just think what ammunition that would have been for the remain campaign yeah i'm sorry i guess i'm certainly playing devil's advocate here but also i think what it does more psychologically i think the falklands were rekindled i mean particularly all the stuff we talked about with the sun the sort of of, you know, the tabloids. If you want to call it jingoism, call it jingoism. That feels very 18th century to me.
我想，好吧，你不能画出——1982年和2016年之间并没有一条简单直接的直线，但如果1982年的结果不同的话——想想这会成为留欧阵营多么强大的弹药啊。是的，抱歉，我想我在这里肯定是在唱反调，但我也认为它在心理上做得更多的是，我认为马岛战争重新点燃了——尤其是我们谈论的所有关于《太阳报》的事情，那种——你知道的——小报风格。如果你想称之为沙文主义，那就叫它沙文主义吧。这让我觉得非常具有18th世纪的风味。
It's very roast beef of old England. Completely. So that's my other question. Yeah. Is that reading about it now, there's an awful lot of stuff about kith and kin and about the kind of the venerable, you know, it's the tradition of Drake.
这非常具有老英格兰的烤牛肉风味。完全是这样。所以这是我的另一个问题。是的。现在读到这些，有很多关于亲朋好友的内容，还有那种令人尊敬的，你知道的，这就是德雷克的传统。
It's a heroic one. The Royal Navy, Britannia ruling the waves. In a way that I think, you know, there are clearly, you know, that still has a lot of resonance for lots of people in britain but one of the things that's striking about it is that everybody involved in you know that we've talked about in this uh in this series is is white and it kind of draws attention to to how much change there's been in the ethnic makeup of britain since 1982 to now and that must complicate the narrative of britain's engagement overseas and the legacy of britain as a great power but i don't think it but i don't think it would i don't think it complicates it as much as if um as if the argentines had i mean the argentines are i agree
这是一个英雄般的传统。皇家海军，不列颠统治海洋。以一种我认为——你知道的——在英国仍然对很多人产生强烈共鸣的方式，但其中最引人注目的一件事情是，你知道的，我们在这个系列节目中谈到的每一个参与者都是白人，这让人注意到自1982年到现在，英国的族群构成发生了多大的变化，这必然会使英国海外介入的叙事以及英国作为大国的遗产变得更加复杂，但我不认为它会——但我不认为它会——我不认为它会像——如果阿根廷人——我的意思是，阿根廷人是——我同意
because the argentines are the ideal villains yeah there's a sentence of spanish and italian immigrants so they're not you know they're descendants of Spanish and Italian immigrants. So they're not an indigenous black population. Now, that would complicate it enormously. So if the Falklands War had been fought again... So, for example, maybe a parallel with the Falklands is the Indian annexation of Goa. So Goa would have been a Portuguese colony.
因为阿根廷人是完美的恶棍。是的，这里有一句关于西班牙和意大利移民的话，所以他们不是，你知道的，他们是西班牙和意大利移民的后裔。所以他们不是本土的黑人群体。现在，那会让情况变得极其复杂。所以，如果马岛战争再次爆发的话……所以，举个例子，也许与马岛相似的是印度吞并果阿。果阿曾是葡萄牙的殖民地。
And India basically... That's in the 60s, isn't it? Yeah, exactly, in the 60s. India annexes it. There's nothing Portugal can do. And from that point on, Goa is Indian. Now, had that been the analogous kind of situation, in other words, had it been a post-colonial country
而印度基本上……那是在60年代，对吧？是的，没错，在60年代。印度吞并了它。葡萄牙对此无可奈何。从那时起，果阿就是印度的了。现在，如果这是类似的情况，换句话说，如果它是一个后殖民国家，
with a kind of indigenous population who had seen themselves as being oppressed by colonial overlords, taking back something that has an ethnic population not unlike their own against their white oppressors, then the Falklands War would obviously look very different today. But it's not like that, is it? Yes, I agree with all that.
拥有某种本土人口——他们认为自己受到殖民统治者的压迫，从他们的白人压迫者手中夺回一些与他们自身的族群人口相差无几的东西，那么今天的马岛战争显然看起来就会非常不同。但事实并非如此，对吗？是的，我同意所有这些。
I just think that with 80% enthusiasm for the Falklands War in 1982, and Union Jacks everywhere, Hearts of Oak, Drake, Nelson, you could say that perhaps it was the last kind of guiltless hurrah for a kind of tradition of exultant patriotism and and that if you know if you want to talk about brexit brexit perhaps for lots of people was a chance to express that again in a way that they felt had been made had been denied them in the intervening period and and perhaps that's why it was so polarizing yeah possibly tom i mean i think i think on the other hand i'm slightly thinking on my feet here yeah but i think the implication of what you're saying though is that the sort of ethnic minority population of britain the non-white population would be among the you know they would be swelling the ranks of the 20 percent um and i'm not sure that's necessarily true i think there'd be an awful lot of yeah there'd be an awful lot of black well i know that yeah that lots lots lots supported
我只是认为，在1982年对马岛战争有80%的热情，到处都是米字旗，“橡树之心”（Hearts of Oak）、德雷克、纳尔逊，你可能会说，这也许是对狂喜爱国主义传统的最后一次毫无负罪感的狂欢，并且——如果你知道的话——如果你想谈论脱欧，脱欧对许多人来说也许是一个再次表达这种情绪的机会，以一种他们觉得在 intervening period（其间）被剥夺了的方式，也许这就是为什么它如此两极分化。是的，有可能，汤姆。我的意思是，另一方面，我有点在即兴思考，是的，但我认为你所说的话的暗示是，英国的少数族裔人口——非白人人口——会成为——你知道的——那20%人群中的一部分，呃，我不确定这是否一定正确，我认为会有非常多的——是的，会有非常多的黑人——嗯，我知道，很多、很多、很多人也支持
brexit as well and also let's imagine imagine imagine a similar situation imagine argentina was currently run by a um a hard right dictatorship that that applied electrodes to the genitals of poets and they invaded the falkland islands tomorrow, what would public opinion be like in Britain? I mean, I don't think... That's a really interesting question. I don't think it would be 52-48. I think it would be more like the 80-20. Well, I suppose the Ukraine, the general support for Ukraine.
脱欧。还有，让我们想象一下，想象一下类似的情况——想象一下阿根廷目前由一个极右翼独裁政权统治，它对诗人的生殖器施加电刑，并且他们明天入侵了马岛，英国的公众舆论会是什么样的？我的意思是，我不认为——这是一个非常有趣的问题。我不认为会是52-48。我认为更可能是80-20。嗯，我想乌克兰，对乌克兰的普遍支持……
Yeah, and I think the 20 would be the same people, by the way. Salman Rushdie margaret drabble polly toynbee jeremy corbin you know a lot of maybe a lot of our listeners um would be among the 20 i'm not i don't want to completely stereotype the 20 but i think the the proportion that would be the sort of retake the islands because i don't think i mean you talked about it as a colonial war now when we think about post-war colonial wars it was a colonial war because this was that this was a colony but but tom when we talk about colonial wars we generally think about two kinds of war
是的，而且我认为那20%的人会是同一拨人，顺便说一句。萨尔曼·拉什迪、玛格丽特·德拉布（Margaret Drabble）、波利·托恩比（Polly Toynbee）、杰里米·科尔宾（Jeremy Corbyn）——你知道的，也许我们的很多听众——会成为那20%的人中的一员，我并不是想完全把那20%的人刻板化，但我觉得，那种倾向于“夺回群岛”的比例——因为我不认为——我的意思是，你把它称为一场殖民战争，现在当我们想到战后的殖民战争时，它之所以是一场殖民战争，是因为这是一块殖民地——但是，汤姆，当我们谈论殖民战争时，我们通常会想到两种战争：
so one is a war where just the the occupying power is trying to suppress a nationalist uprising so that would be you know the french and algeria well i mean actually no that's a different guy the other is where you're backing settlers against an indigenous population so so one is very straightforward it's occupiers and occupied and the other the settlers involved the falklands is not quite like either of those things because there is no so to keep saying that it's the perfect colonial war because none of those complexities are involved in it yeah but that makes it different from almost any other colonial i i agree but i do also think that there's that attitudes to the empire have and i know that this you know mr satcher wasn't interested
一种是占领国试图镇压民族主义起义的战争，所以这就是——你知道的——法国人在阿尔及利亚（嗯，其实不对，那是另一回事）；另一种是你支持定居者对抗本土人口的战争。所以一种非常简单明了，就是占领者和被占领者；另一种涉及定居者。马岛战争跟这两种都不太一样，因为没有——所以一直在说这是一场完美的殖民战争，是因为其中不涉及任何这些复杂性。是的，但这就使它不同于几乎任何其他殖民战争——我同意，但我也确实认为，对帝国的态度已经——我知道——撒切尔夫人对帝国不感兴趣，
in the empire the falklands war wasn't about trying to recreate the empire i understand that but it was nevertheless a colonial war and i I do think that attitudes to the empire have become more complicated. Of course they have. Now, what's really interesting is, so the phrase that's sometimes used with the Falklands War is the empire strikes back, most famously by Newsweek magazine. Yes, it's the task force setting off. It's the task force. But the first use of it that I found when I wrote my book was among soldiers themselves themselves they have it written on a kind of blanket that they're hanging over the side of one of the ships as they leave so it's being generated as it were from below and it's among
马岛战争不是为了试图重塑帝国，我明白这一点，但它仍然是一场殖民战争，我确实认为对帝国的态度已经变得更加复杂了。当然是的。现在，真正有趣的是——所以，有时用来形容马岛战争的一个短语是“帝国反击战”，最著名的是由《新闻周刊》杂志提出的。是的，那是特遣舰队启航。那是特遣舰队。但我写书时发现的它的最早用法是在士兵中间，
the the troops the young men in their early 20s obviously because they're the target audience for star wars they've seen the film yeah so just a year a year or two earlier um how much is this a war of nostalgia for empire i don't think it is about nostalgia for empire i think it's not no i don't think it's i don't think it's a it's nostalgia for this thomas is nostalgia for the second world war i think yeah i know i think it's even more than that i think it's nostalgia for britain ruling the waves i think it's uh hearts of oak it's um nelson it's it's it's nostalgia for a world in which Britain uncomplicatedly rules the waves. It's not a nostalgia for the implications of why Britain rules the waves.
他们把它写在一条毯子上，挂在其中一艘船的侧面作为他们离开时的标语。所以它是从底层产生的，可以说是源于部队，源于那些20岁出头的年轻小伙子们——显然，因为他们是《星球大战》的目标受众，他们看过这部电影，是的——所以就在一两年前，这在多大程度上是一场对帝国怀旧的战争？我不认为这是关于对帝国的怀旧。我认为它不是——不，我不认为它是——我不认为这是对帝国的怀旧，汤姆，这是对二战的怀旧，我想。是的，我懂，我认为这甚至更多，我认为这是对“不列颠统治海洋”的怀旧。我认为这是——“橡树之心”，这是——纳尔逊，这是——对一个英国毫无疑问地统治海洋的世界的怀旧。这不是对英国为什么要统治海洋背后的含义的怀旧。
Well, let me just read you this. I think it's sea shanties and, well, Drake and all that kind of stuff. Of course. Let me just read you a couple of things. So one is, let's go back to the 5th of April. So that's when the task force leaves from Portsmouth. The Daily Mail had a bloke there who interviews one of them at crowd. The guy in the crowd is called Tommy Mallon. He is a veteran of World War I. And this is what he says. He says, was done for spineless a doormat for the world i'd pass the war memorials or see nelson's victory and i'd wonder what it had all been for but i was wrong thank god we're still a proud country and we'll still protect our own so that's right so it's but it's the protecting our own yeah well that obviously i think that that has become more complicated yes i think that's that's fair because what he means by our own is people
好吧，让我读给你听一段。我想那是海员号子，还有——德雷克和所有这些东西。当然。让我读给你听几件事。一是，让我们回到4月5日。那是特遣舰队从朴茨茅斯出发的时候。当时《每日快报》有一位记者在那里采访了人群中的一个人。人群中的这个人叫汤米·马伦（Tommy Mallon）。他是一位一战老兵。这就是他所说的话。他说：
from britain who went out in the 19th century uh well i think so jonathan raven had who we talked about in one who had this brilliant book um uh about um um sailing around the coast of britain um brilliant travel writer he says at one, the thing about the Falkland Islanders is they look like Britons from the 1950s. I mean, you're right, Tom, he means white Britons because they speak and they sound and they look
嗯，我想是的。乔纳森·拉班（Jonathan Raban），我们之前在某期节目中谈到过他，他有一本非常精彩的书——关于沿着英国海岸航行的事——他是一位出色的游记作家，他说，关于马岛居民，有一点是他们看起来像20世纪50年代的英国人。我的意思是，你是对的，汤姆，他指的是白人英国人，因为他们的言谈举止，而且他们看起来——
physically because of the way they're dressed. Cause they're old fashioned because their stuff's having to be imported. Well, it was, it was all that kind of, you know, the, the,
从外表上看，因为他们的穿着方式。因为他们很过时，因为他们的东西都得进口。嗯，是的，都是那种——你知道的——
the archers stuff that, that we, that you were talking about when the, when the British troops land. Yeah, exactly. There's like, you know,
《万物既伟大又渺小》（All Creatures Great and Small）里的那些东西，就是我们在——就是当英军登陆时你们在谈论的那些。是的，完全是。就像是，你知道的，
have leads been relegated. Yeah. You've taken the time to do an episode of all creatures, great and small. Yes. Yeah, exactly. So I think this,
利兹（Leads）被降职了吗？是的。你花时间做了一集关于《万物既伟大又渺小》的节目。是的。是的，完全是。所以我觉得，
I mean, there's a writer called Anthony Barnett, who's actually a very, very big remainer and has written tons of stuff. Yes. I've people's people's votes, all this sort of business. I've shared a taxi with him.
我的意思是，有一位作家叫安东尼·巴尼特（Anthony Barnett），他实际上是一个非常、非常坚定的留欧派，写了大量的东西。是的。人们的投票，所有这些事情。我和他共乘过一辆出租车。
There you go. Across Greece. He's the husband of Judith Herron, isn't he? He is, yes. He's an anti-historian. So he wrote a really, really... I mean, I don't personally necessarily agree with him, but I find it really insightful and interesting.
你看。穿过希腊。他是朱迪思·赫伦（Judith Herron）的丈夫，对吧？他是，是的。他是一位反历史学家。所以他写了一篇非常、非常——我的意思是，我个人不一定同意他的观点，但我发现它真的很有见地、很有趣。
He wrote a really good... I can't remember if it was an essay or a book in the immediate aftermath of the Fulton's War in which he says... I mean, he noticed that something had changed and he calls it Churchillism. And he says, the whole thing is drenched in this obsessive nostalgia for the summer of 1940, but also for D-Day, obviously.
他写了一篇非常好的——我记不清是在马岛战争结束后不久写的一篇随笔还是一本书，他在其中说——我的意思是，他注意到有什么东西变了，他称之为“丘吉尔主义”（Churchillism）。他说，整件事情都浸透在这种对1940年夏天的痴迷怀旧中，当然也对诺曼底登陆充满怀旧。
The idea of standing alone, the idea of an island people, the idea of fascists, the prime minister who rises to the moment, the standing for freedom, that we're just a little people, our men with their backpacks yomping across the moors. Bubble hats. All of this, yeah, all of that stuff. And the naval stuff is a huge element of that because it's so deeply rooted in Britain's self-image.
孤军奋战的想法，作为一个岛国人民的想法，法西斯分子的想法，挺身而出的首相，为自由而战的想法，我们只是一个微小的人民，我们的士兵背着背包在荒原上跋涉。毛线帽。所有这些，是的，所有这些东西。而海军元素是其中的一个巨大组成部分，因为它深深植根于英国的自我形象中。
But I think a lot of that iconography obviously was used in 2016 and completely even among people who didn't vote to leave the eu i think it still has a huge pull doesn't it i mean uh yes but i think it also has a huge repulsion effect i think lots of people are a lot you know as jonathan rabin was yeah find it unsettling and frightening and disturbing well yeah and i think that that is what made brexit and the um the debate that followed brexit so visceral on both sides i think so alan bennett the playwright uh who's of course another great remainer writes a uh an annual big diary column for the London Review of Books. He wrote a piece saying, you know, I don't, after this result.
但我认为其中很多图像在2016年显然被使用了，而且完全——甚至在那些没有投票离开欧盟的人中间——它仍然具有巨大的吸引力，不是吗？我的意思是——是的，但我也认为它具有巨大的排斥效应。我认为很多人——你知道的——正如乔纳森·拉班所说的那样——觉得它令人不安、可怕和困扰。嗯，是的，而且我认为正是这一点使得脱欧以及脱欧之后的辩论在双方都如此激烈。我想也是。戏剧家阿兰·贝内特（Alan Bennett），当然是另一位伟大的留欧派，为《伦敦书评》（London Review of Books）撰写年度大型日记专栏。他写了一篇文章说，你知道的，我不——在这个结果之后。
After the Falklands. Well, wait. After this result, I don't feel English. You know, there are people singing Robert's Hand and these kind of vulgar people. I don't, I feel like everything I believed in has been turned on its head. And he's not talking about the Brexit.
在马岛战争之后。等等。在这个结果之后，我不再觉得自己是英国人了。你知道，有人在唱《耶路撒冷》（Jerusalem）和这些粗俗的人。我不再——我觉得我所相信的一切都被颠覆了。而他谈论的不是脱欧。
He's talking about the Falklands war, but he basically writes the same column again. Okay. Okay. So yeah. So, all right. So I think I,
他谈论的是马岛战争，但他基本上又写了内容相同的专栏。好吧。好吧。所以——好吧，我想我——
you have completely convinced me that the Falklands reverberate into the present. Okay. Maybe it doesn't cause Brexit, but, but, but it amplifies trends that culminate in Brexit. I don't think you can talk. I think, I think the two are on the, yeah, exactly. They're on the same Brexit. I don't think you can talk.
你彻底说服了我，马岛战争的影响一直延续到了现在。好吧。也许它没有直接导致脱欧，但是，但是，但是它放大了最终导致脱欧的趋势。我不认为你可以说——我认为，我认为这两者在——是的，准确地说，它们处于同一连续体上。我不懂。我现在在这个问题上已经混淆了太多的隐喻。你认为这证明了做这么长一期节目的合理性吗？绝对的。我认为是的。但我想很多人，汤姆，可能渴望听到的不是更多关于马岛战争的内容，而是可能去阅读更多——
I think the two are on the, yeah, exactly. They're on the same continuum. I don't know. I've mixed metaphors on this now so many times. And do you think that justifies for almost the long episodes on it? Definitely. I think it does. But I think a lot of people, Tom, will be keen maybe not to hear more about the Falklands War but possibly to read more
但去阅读——难道你不认为——我想他们会的。所以我要再次推荐你的那本书，《强者胜：英国1979年至1982年》（Who Dares Wins: Britain, 1979 to 1982）。我和我的妻子萨迪（Sadie）谈过这件事，我们去了康沃尔一家非常奇特的酒店，那是个特价房，所以我们愚蠢地接受了。那是一家糟糕的酒店，有点像《巴斯 Fawlty Towers 酒店》式的，而且雨下个不停，所以我们只能呆在糟糕潮湿的酒店房间里。但我有你的书，大约有7000页，说真的，多米尼克，那是我一生中最棒的阅读体验之一。我想我是实时发推特分享的，所以你能看出我有多享受。而且——马岛战争那部分，有四章对吧？我认为那是最高明的巅峰，
but to read but do you not think I think they would I'm gonna so I'm gonna recommend it again your book on this Who Dares Wins Britain 1979 to 1982 and I was talking about this with Sadie my wife we we went to a very peculiar hotel in Cornwall it was a special offer and so we took foolishly took it up it was a terrible hotel kind of faulty towers-esque and it just rained solidly and so we stayed in our awful damp hotel room but i had your book which is about 7 000 pages and i honestly dominic it was one of the great reading experiences of my life i think i live tweeted it so you were able to tell how much i was enjoying it and and the the the falklands war is just there are four chapters aren't there it's the most brilliant climax i
我认为这是当代历史写作中最伟大的篇章之一。哦，汤姆，你过奖了。我真的——我做了什么才配得上这样的夸奖？不过这本书的其余部分也很精彩，但马岛那部分绝对是神来之笔。所以，强烈、强烈推荐它。多米尼克，非常感谢。谢谢你，汤姆。谢谢你听我滔滔不绝。哦，绝对是我的荣幸。呃，自从我们开始做这个podcast以来，我一直很期待这一天，而且我们记得我当时说——你知道的，我希望我们还在坚持录制，是的——为了纪念周年纪念日。令人难以置信的是，我们还在坚持。所以非常感谢大家的收听，如果你坚持听到了这里，你们这仅有的四位——再见，再见。谢谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取独家单集、抢先收听、无广告体验以及访问我们的聊天社区，
think it's your one of the great passages of uh contemporary history oh tom you're too kind i really what have i done to deserve this but the rest of the rest of the book is fabulous as well but the the the falklands it's absolutely bravura writing so uh highly highly recommend it Dominic thanks so much thank you Tom thank you for listening to me have my head no absolute pleasure uh I've been looking forward to it ever since we started this podcast and we remember I was kind of saying you know I hope we're still going yeah um for the anniversary and incredibly we are so uh thanks very much for listening if you've made it this far all four of you um bye bye bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community,
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。也就是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一丝八卦的好去处。在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐界的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家单集和抢先购买现场演出门票，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets,
请前往 therestisentertainment.com。也就是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。